yo yo Mr White Brian you're so
sexy good morning uh good
morning I know who it is but I just want
you to keep doing
it hi I'm Brian Cranston hi I'm Sam
Rockwell and this is First Impressions
here we go I'll
start you even know who the person is
well it's not the
person it's it's Ringo will George
Harrison yes but more of a group fact
beetles in general nicely done nicely
done okay Li pudlin my turn here oh
you're going to do two at once that
would be hard by the way I could do it
pal oh sh oh yeah Marty it's important
we're going to the Future Marty yeah
Marty come off for you follow me yeah uh
uh well Christopher Lloyd but okay I
didn't know if it was the character or
it was the character it was the
character I didn't get I like a brain
trauma brain shake from that do okay
here we go another one oh this is going
to be very hard
actually yo
uh hand your Dice Clay no uh yo Mr
White Aaron Paul yes yeah very good well
that's pretty good jeez that's close to
home just going to S two six once you've
done with your cards just Hoy them off
the table whoever you like the least in
the room
okay paper you just got him in the eye
Jesus
Christ um oh oh
oh hi Brian what are you doing I'm TR
want you to come Trum M capot no Brian
you're so
sexy I'm I I'm I'm going to Thailand to
do White Lotus and oh Mike
White Mike doesn't talk like this oh oh
you're so beautiful a great yeah yes yes
you're such a great you're so handsome
oh I got you yes Brian what are we what
are you doing
later blanking on her name that's the
all right but we know we get the idea
yeah I can't go on doing this horrible
impersonation it's Jennifer kulage
Groundlings went to the Groundlings bran
I know I forgot the name trained
improvisation tongue oh yeah do I go
shopping now or does someone do that for
me very good is that yeah you obviously
had a writer do you know how that was
okay
um got
there
shall we
dance wow I love it but
who give me something come what else
kiss me can you dance well me who the
hell is it it's not
me who the hell is it agent ar oh uh uh
C do a Lia yes yes that's a perfect do
AA too oh thank you for that he got me
in the neck all right here we go uh jeez
this is tough okay okay
um he uh yes
um I'm going to put on a helmet I'm in a
suit I fly
around and then I have a cane and I walk
like this
I walk like
that like a famous person suit and a
helmet and
I I'm really mad at Oppenheimer
Oppenheimer no bueno on Oppenheimer who
am I oh yeah I'm I'm getting that
Oppenheimer dude I'm
getting it's a terrible AG are you an
Iron Man yes I am Robert Downey Jr yes
did you see my Charlie Chaplain walk
yeah but that threw me that was the wait
a minute you said I have you put on a
helmet and I and then you walk like this
it's like you put on a helmet and walk I
threw too much at you I threw too much I
threw too much at it I got I
got it was good it was good
sorry this is a tough one
okay uh Spider-Man Toby mcgu uh um uh uh
uh looks kind of like
me
God damn it Spider-Man
impression it's
Spider-Man uh uh uh uh God damn it I
have this I have this character in my
mind I'll call him
Spider-Man oh uh
stanlee look at that we're acing this
man but I could I there's no way I can
do a voice impression of Stan Lee that's
too that's like forget it but you have
this
one come on are you kidding me guys
what
um I know who it is but I just want you
to keep doing
it you are chip the cat I am just a cat
apparently a cat not a celebrity cat
just a generic cat you know what really
made me get it is I started to get a
scratchy throat cuz I'm allergic to that
good I am I gave him an
allergy very nice
okay that's a
challenge all right um let's step up
shall
we uh good
morning uh Pryce it's a beautiful day no
good morning uh good
morning um Brian
Cranston on on cocaine no good morning
hi
Ken uh Barbie Barbie Barbie Barbie uh
Margo Robbie yes I was trying to look
beautiful but I I couldn't pull that off
the eyes I got some drugs for that you
got
some um yeah Margo Robbie that's Maro
Robie I said Barbie okay this is it if
it do it
count uh I don't know man like n like
it's stupid man oh no
man who I can't do this wait maybe I
should pass on this yeah yeah yeah let
me see it let me can you do that
one oh can you do this uh I'm like the
best answer ever better better yeah it's
a it's a tiger and a lion that made it
can you guys guess who that is I was
going to say Jennifer kage yeah nicely
done Jennifer coolage again Jennifer CL
oh God damn it well it was supposed to
be Napoleon Dynamite yeah but clear we
pooched that didn't we maybe not
Dynamite maybe not Dynamite that was
just Napoleon when he was you know
through his troubles in France pregame
yeah when he was just a soldier I I'm
the king of
France and people are angry with me I
don't really know
why but okay let's make a movie I'm
really small yeah and I have a big my
God that's Ridley Scott he's going to
direct me he is so cool that's really
how he
spoke Ryan
wll wow that's wow
such aggression should we arm wrestle
yeah maybe let's arm wrestle all right
ready all
right oh oh God I just hit your nut sack
sorry that means I won
wait a second Arnold
Schwarz Arnold schwarzer that's so funny
because she does the most ridiculous
impersonation of Arnold schwarzer and I
recognize you recogniz